thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video give them on my dear love and a
kiss give them all my dear love and the
kids tell them I think of them by day
pray for them by night and find my best
comforts and their affection at all
times
a year seems a very long time to wait
before I see them
but remind them that while we wait we
may all works for these hard days need
not be wasted
I really enjoyed credit girl wigs 2019
adaptation of Little Women it turned out
to be one of my favorite films from the
year but girl wigs adaptation is far
from the first the book Little Women
written by louisa may alcott in 1800s
has an unbelievable amount of screen
adaptations I didn't know anyone was
here that offensive stay if you like
you see I don't know anyone so I feel
rather strange at first yeah so do I
miss March isn't it yes mr. Lawrence but
I'm not miss March I'm only chill I'm
Laurie Laurie Joe much ah
besides girl wigs version in just the
last three years we also had a version
up with the story and a modern setting
sorry sorry avoiding people what need to
I'm only here because my grandpa thinks
that I need to make friends I guess when
your grandpa thinks that you're a loner
you probably are so you're the infamous
Lawrence grandson infamous and in 2017
there was a masterpiece theater
adaptation starring Maya honk as Joe
hello again don't you care for the party
either
it's lovely it's just I don't know many
people me neither
and I have a headache me too the first
film adaptation of the story was in 1917
as a silent film there was another film
adaptation just a year after that in
1918 I wasn't able to find copies of
these versions the first available film
adaptation we have is the 1933 version
starring Katharine Hepburn as Jo March I
mean I I promised I wouldn't why there's
the 1949 adaptation why not don't you
like to dies I love to lonely I promised
I wouldn't Oh of all the silly why why
look in the 1994 adaptation which is the
adaptation I saw as a kid which is
pretty good and features a great cast
there are several other TV adaptations
and even multiple anime adaptations
[Music]
however did you get stuck with that one
well my real name's Theodore actually
why do you call yourself Laurie well you
see when I was away at school all the
boys started calling me Dora and that's
the name I absolutely hated so I had to
beat a few of them up to make them stop
teasing me with so many adaptations over
the years besides the predictably
excellent 824 cast and Meryl Streep what
is Greta Gerwig with her 2019 adaptation
really bringing to the table well by
setting scenes from the film adaptation
side-by-side we can begin to see let's
take a look at the scene where Laurie
proposes to Joe
don't feel too badly Joe you still got
me
you've still got me who I'm not good for
much I know when I imagine myself and in
that life I could think of only one
thing
don't oh no I don't I will and you must
hear me oh it's nice knowing you Joe
ciao
will you listen to what I want to tell
you know Laurie don't say hi I will and
you must hear me no Teddy Teddy don't
[Music]
Laurie in the three other film
adaptations it remains fairly similar
Gerwig steak on the scene doesn't change
the story beat but it brings something
new to the table emotionally and
visually you don't have to stay here
yeah why should we run off and join the
pirate ship
[Music]
no no it's no use Joe Joe we've got to
have it out I have loved you ever since
I've known you Joe I couldn't help it
there's a motion in the blocking and
energy in the camera work that just
doesn't exist in these other scenes the
scene is alive in a way that I really
like she's using blocking effectively to
help bring the struggle between these
characters to life on screen
lovely accomplished girl love you and
adore you and and she's gonna make a
fine mistress for your fine house but I
wouldn't alright I'm homely and awkward
and you'd be ashamed I love you Joe and
we can't help it even now we don't need
quite Woodhams
you can't even propose without working I
know we would quark no we wouldn't we
always have you know everything would be
hurried and we should we always it's a
technique that girl wigs partner Noah
Baumbach is also great at and I've
talked about at depth in a video I did
for Netflix
well visual energy and motion aren't the
only thing Gerwig is bringing to the
table we can also see how she's using
editing and cinematography to position
the scene in a different emotional space
than the previous adaptations well these
three films play this moment fairly
close and intimate between Laurie and
Joe someday you'll change you'll meet
some good-for-nothing no-account fool
you'll fall in love with him and work
and live and die for him as you will
you'll meet some good-for-nothing
no-account idiot and you'll fall in love
with him and work and live and die for
him I know you
meet some man good man and you will love
him tremendously Gerwig plays it wider
her wigs version is not tragic in a
romantic way I love my Liberty to well
to be in any hurry to give it up I think
you're wrong about that general I think
you will marry Joe I think you'll find
someone and love them and you will live
and die for them because that's your way
and you will not watch its tragedy is
more of a frustrating inevitability
[Music]
we can see again the visual energy that
Gerwig is adding in the scene where
Laurie and Joe secretly dance at the
ball there's a playful energy and the
camerawork and blocking that Gerwig
brings to this scene that doesn't exist
in any of the other adaptations I'm
showing here
[Music]
it's not that simply adding motion is
automatically better but I think the
energy Gerwig ads really seems to fit
the energy of the protagonist Jill March
and the story as a whole and it's one of
the reasons why I think this new
adaptation feels justified one of the
fascinating things that these
comparisons reveal is how much there is
to an adaptation
besides dialogue two scenes like this
can have entirely different dialogue
while still hitting many of the same
subtextual beats like the way Joe eats
the way she sits and handles herself is
it true that you lived in Italy among
artists and vagrants my mother was
Italian a pianist where is he
volunteers for the Union Army actually
I'm going to Europe well at least I hope
I am and I wanted to go fight with him I
can't get over my disappointment of
being a girl you do if I were gonna be a
writer I'd go to New York and pursue the
stage are you shocked
very the same information about her
character can be expressed using
different lines of dialogue I think
perhaps the most interesting part of
girl wakes adaptation is its
relationship to the other adaptations
contextually I think this adaptation is
a version for people who already know
the story who have seen other
adaptations or have read the book it
will still make sense to anyone who's
experiencing it for the first time but
for those who already know the story the
way it plays with that story will add
something new to their experience a key
aspect of this is the nonlinear approach
this contrasts the sisters older and
later in life
against a very idealized portrait of
their youth placing these scenes in
direct juxtaposition adds a nostalgia
and melancholy to the story that I don't
think is as present in the other
versions this romantic nostalgia is
reinforced through the score and the
painterly lighting and Composition fit
you Marmee she went I was at the crack
of dawn just hey just something German
where is mommy coming goodness only
knows some poor creature came a big and
your mom sent straight off to see what
was leader could help other people at a
time convenient to watch she just went
down the street but you'd be right that
she want you to have your breakfast when
I can get it na Gerwig takes liberties
with the books ending which I'm going to
spoil here so fair warning if you
haven't seen the movie or read the book
every other film adaptation ends the
same way I have nothing to give but my
heart so cool and and this empty penance
well here's
and these empty hands not empty now or
chill but I had nothing to give you my
hands are empty
not empty now
my hands are empty
[Music]
I love it it's romantic it's very moving
that's very emotional and Gerwig version
Joe's acceptance of Professor
Friedreich's proposal only happens in
Joe's in movie book she doesn't actually
marry him and while this is a change
from the original story it's done as an
attempt to maintain the feminist spirit
of the original book so who does she
marry no one she doesn't marry either of
them no and it creates an ode to author
Louisa May Alcott who herself remained
unmarried her entire life and for whom
the book was at least partially
autobiographical well she says the whole
book that she doesn't want to marry who
cares Gerwig makes the assertion that
all cotton may have preferred for Joe to
stay unmarried in the book but was
pressured to give the story a
traditional romantic ending by
publishers and when we don't know if
this is the case her wigs version
becomes a commentary on the way the
previous adaptations still present Joe's
engagement as the climactic event in her
life girls want to see women married not
consistent isn't the right the right
ending is the one that sells while the
book extends one chapter past this
moment every other film adaptation we've
looked at ends right here like the book
Gerwig extends the story past where the
other films end the climax of girl wigs
version is not joe's eventual engagement
but the publishing of her book the
film's stronger nostalgic and
melancholic tone play a role here
Joe's problems aren't all solved by an
engagement I'm so sick of people saying
that that love is just all a woman is
hateful I'm so sick of it I'm so lonely
she's accomplished something satisfying
but it isn't without loss and hardship
along the way and here girl wigs use of
the nonlinear story structure plays a
thematic role because we see Joe and
Lori separate from the beginning and meg
and John already married it takes the
focus of the story away from the
audience waiting to see who will and
won't get married and shifts it to the
sisters lives
and how they're grappling with loss and
growing older Gerwig shows us why it can
be worth creating yet another adaptation
of something that's been adapted so many
times not only does she bring a higher
level of artistry and direction by
giving the film a new level of energy
through blocking and cinematography but
she positions the story as a reflection
on the past adaptations the values and
message of the story itself and the life
of the author a lot of us are stuck at
home right now with some extra time so
it's a great time to dive into an
audiobook just like there are many
different film adaptations of Little
Women audible has many audio book
versions of Little Women
you could choose the version with the
narrator you prefer or you could choose
the audible original dramatization that
features Laura Dern as part of a full
cast you could get one of these
audiobooks for free when you sign up for
a 30-day free trial at audible.com slash
Thomas played choose one audiobook and
two audible originals absolutely free
visit honorable comm slash thomas play
or text thomas flight 2 500 500 thanks
again to audible for sponsoring this
video thanks so much for watching and a
special thank you to my patrons for
their support if you want to support
what I do go to patreon.com/scishow
slight
[Music]